so you're a statesman maybe you're an
idealist looking to make a difference in
the world as a state governor senator or
maybe as a president maybe you've got
more ambitious goals or ruling with an
iron this as a dictator or maybe you're
just a powerful businessman looking to
protect your interests from the frenzy
of the greedy masses whatever it may be
back in the good old days of monarchs
kings queens and emperors ruling over
your plebs was pretty simple
they didn't have the right to vote they
didn't have any influence over your rule
whatsoever all the power rested in your
more nobler hands as it should so their
only choice was to obey or get sent to
the labor camp the guillotine or
whatever suits your fancy but around the
18th and 19th century something happened
that would forever changed the course of
history and your role as a noble
statesman more and more nations gave men
not just the opportunity to go but to
give their votes some real way and
influence behind them that people are
friends overthrew their monarchies
stripping away their rulers power the
American colonies did the impossible by
defeating the British Empire makes in a
bunch of scientific and industrial
discoveries and all of a sudden within a
relatively short timespan
humanity shifted from power to the state
to power to the people the Divine Right
of Kings was replaced with the Divine
Right of the masses the people now
dictated how the Kings should act not
the king himself it's now the masses
voices that hold all the influence with
the rulers desires cast in the sidelines
it's the heart of the masses that
determine the destiny of Nations instead
of those in charge and as humanity
gradually shifts more and more power to
the people instead of the state the only
real power left is the power of crowds
and it's those rare breeds that
understand crowd psychology that
understand how to win the hearts and
minds of the masses that get all the
power that win the elections that take
the dictatorships those that don't
understand my psychology well they end
up like not a movement of we work or
Elizabeth Holmes of Thoreau knows some
of the most hated people in America at
one point in time so if you want all the
power or any sort of power for that
matter
if you want to not govern over people
because that's no longer possible but to
at least not be governed by them
you better understand the popular mind
[Music]
crowds have taken over the world
employers have to listen to labor unions
elected officials can be voted out of
office and crowds have proven time and
time again that if they don't get what
they want they will eventually resort to
violence
the most important historical upheavals
the rise and fall of civilizations
weren't because of the revolutions wars
or invasions themselves but because of
the profound changes in the public's
ideas beliefs and sentiments that led to
most revolutions the American Revolution
wasn't because the colonists rebelled
against a British nananana it was
because the collective masses of the
colonies believe that risking their
lives in the violent war that they have
very little chance of winning was worth
it or in other words the memorable
events of history are the visible
effects of the invisible changes of
human thought it all comes down to what
the masses believe most of us like to
think that we're very rational creatures
that we don't make decisions simply
because other people are doing the same
thing no I'm an independent thinker but
little do we realize just how
susceptible you and I are to the
influence of crowds when we talk about
crowds were not simply referring to when
a bunch of people are rarely guard
together a crowd or a psychological
crowd is when people are joined together
by an idea a cause or beliefs this could
be an in person crowd at a protest or
riot or a bunch of people rallying
behind the same cause over the Internet
crowds can be centered around their race
religion political beliefs their
profession music tastes or simply by
people identifying as a citizen of the
country they're in and the moment you
join a crowd you act and think very
differently too when you're alone your
beliefs are merged together with the
beliefs of everyone else in the crowd
you lose your personality to the
collective personality of the crowd the
logical side of your brain shuts down
your intellect and reasoning abilities
go down to make way from the more
primitive side of yourself to be set
free a single collective - formed the
crowd becomes bigger and more powerful
than the individuals making it up much
like how individual cells come together
and out emerges something greater you as
a member of a crowd you are like a cell
setting aside your own interest to fight
for the
good of the organism you become a
barbaric irrational cog in the wheel
acting on instinct this is because as
humans were primarily ruled by our
unconscious mind the same unconscious
mind that keeps us breathing in our
hearts beating without us having to
consciously worry about it the
unconscious mind is also home to all the
primitive instincts designed to keep us
alive back in the hunter-gatherer days
and in those hunter-gatherer days of
being in a crowd or tribe and
contributing to that tribe gave us a
much higher chance of survival than if
we were to venture off on our own even
though today we might be very different
from each other superficially we have
different jobs wear different clothes
etc our unconscious character however is
virtually identical that's why when we
join a crowd all those superficial
intellectual differences are crushed and
the unconscious side of everyone merges
together that's why crowds are rather
stupid and are never capable of doing
anything that requires intellect since
that side of their brain is shut off
they can only do primal things that
anyone else can do which is why ello
there can be positive crowds that make a
positive difference when there's the
right leader and influences in place
most of the time
crowds are only good for one thing
destruction because on top of having the
rational side of your brain turned off
when you're in a crowd you also get the
feeling of being invincible when
Outsiders are looking in they don't say
hey look at what that guy is doing no
they say hey look at what they are doing
you're
free of any sense of personal
responsibility in a crowd people's
strong emotions are so contagious that
you'll want to join in on that greater
good sacrificing your own personal
interest for the cause the crowd is
fighting for it whether that be donating
some of your hard-earned money that you
usually wouldn't let go of all the way
to enlisting in the military during a
time of war to make yourself feel like
you're doing your part for the crowd of
the country you'll eventually get put
into a somewhat hypnotic state where
you're open to the influence of
suggestion that actions and sentiments
of others act as social proof to how you
should be behaving if people are
publicly shaming a guy on the internet
they disagree with you might as well do
your part and throw in some hate
comments that you wouldn't normally say
if everyone else is charging through no
man's land getting blown to bits well
obviously we can't be the chump staying
in the trenches now can we charge
forward combine the hypnotic state with
the amplifies stupidity the contagion of
emotions the feeling of being invincible
and you can see that it doesn't take
much for you to let loose all those
primitive urges that you've been
bottling up inside you as a civilized
member of society
when the chips are down
these these civilized people they'll eat
each other
worse yet people need to join crowds
they crave it especially those at the
bottom of society those have spent their
whole lives repressing their desires not
going after their dreams those that can
be the life that others have those that
feel powerless why the hell what I want
to be an individual but has to take
responsibility and ownership for where
my life is at when I can let myself lose
and experience a sense of that fleeting
power but I never get to experience in
my day-to-day life as a barbaric member
of a crowd so now that we know the inner
workings of crowds let's see how we can
use this to our advantage as a person in
a position of power
[Music]
remember no crowds are rather stupid by
design won't because they're so stupid
they desperately need a master to guide
them this is where you come in going
back to those tribal days of our
ancestors every tribe had a leader
that's why today whenever you join a
crowd you instinctually fall under the
influence of a leader just like how
people crave being in crowds
they crave having a charismatic leader
to follow through the ends of the earth
someone to tell them what their opinion
should be to direct their anger or
desire for change in the right direction
what direction you may ask whatever
direction you want put the few caveats
if we're talking about the typical
political or social justice crowds since
they're typically made up of those at
the bottom of society with lots of
repressed desires like we talked about
earlier the easiest way to sway them and
become their master is to call for
equality fairness that we should take
down those greedy of elites at the top
even though you're one of them that know
your life isn't words at because of you
it's because of them over there taking
more of their fair share whether that's
true or not but be warned and just as
easily as you can rile up a crowd
towards your enemies another leader can
just ask easily direct their anger
towards you that's why it's important
not to look too perfect in the eyes of
the populace and not look too wealthy or
better than them
remember crowds are incapable of
high-level thinking so they'll go
towards the easiest low-hanging targeted
make sure that isn't you make sure your
life looks modest to outsiders maybe
make some generous public donations here
and there and for the love of God before
you do any questionable business deal
put yourself in the shoes of an angry
mob what their primitive Minds approve
of your actions
if yes proceed if no either don't do it
or you better make sure that it never
gets out but whatever kind of crowded is
the primary job of a leader is to arouse
faith in your subjects faith is the key
faith gives men the power to move
mountains as by crowds become bigger
than the individuals that make it up
it's by wars are won by the sila has
more faith not necessarily more
firepower I'm not talking about
religious faith here either
just that invigorating feeling of faith
in general give people something to
believe in with a few more copy outs as
we mentioned earlier a psychological
crowd as when people come together
behind an idea and it's the job of the
leader to bring down that idea to the
masses but since crowds aren't
intelligent the idea can't be too
complex it has to be boiled down dumbed
down to a level so basic that your
primitive mind can understand sure the
leaders of the American Revolution were
inspired by the writings of people like
Thomas Paine or John Locke but came
crowd to really rally behind the essay
concerning human understanding
I think nuts you know what they can
rally behind freedom
Keep America great
what's you do boil down that idea you
have to get the crowd to act it's pretty
easy to get a crowd to temporarily do
something whether that be to pillage a
village to storm enemy lines to riot in
the streets especially when there's some
kind of catalyst event a sudden wrongful
death an act of war etc all you need is
an inspirational speech a sad story and
off they go
however if you really want to change the
mind of a crowd to really change their
beliefs to get them to believe that
diamonds are valuable for example we
have to resort to more subtle long-term
tactics the first step is a simple
affirmation diamonds are forever a
religious prayer in the Pledge of
Allegiance
don't try to add any reasoning or logic
to the affirmation there's nothing
logical about the statement diamonds are
forever the simpler and more concise it
is the better affirmations don't really
do much without the second step however
repetition the more the affirmation is
repeated let's say with lots of diamonds
are forever ads and movie integrations
over years and years and years the more
we start to forget who originally made
that claim and the more we start to
accept it as just the truth once one
person accepts the repeated affirmation
as truth it gets very nasty once one
sheep in the herd starts to panic and
next thing you know the entire herd is
also panicking once one person accepts
the affirmation as truth that belief
will quickly spread to those around him
and soon to the entire crowd this is
what's called contagion and moom you now
know how crowds work you know our
primitive desire to join crowds or
tribes you know how to avoid the
destruction of crowds by not building up
any Envy with them and you know how to
beat the charismatic leader and they
still desperately crave by boiling down
an idea to inspire faith in them and you
know how to inculcate new beliefs into a
crowd through repeating an affirmation
until it becomes the truth and goes
viral so now you can get out there and
start your rule welcome to the watch
Latin club I just want to make this
video as a gentle reminder to like have
your own opinions and stuff but try your
best not to get sucked into the mob
mentality too much I am definitely not
immune to this I catch myself in that
mass psychology state like all the time
and I think it should be our
responsibility to try to stay as
rational as we can for as much as we can
if you enjoyed this video consider
subscribing because there is plenty of
more free video essays just like this
one coming out every
a week for free for your viewing
pleasure if you want to support this
channel financially you can join the
trend mafia family also known as patreon
you can follow me on instagram for me
use behind-the-scenes stuff sometimes I
post teasers for new videos on there
which is Jake trend IO so thank you so
much for watching that is enough plugs
for this video you've been awesome I've
been Jake I'll see you guys in the next
one
[Music]